so today at about 7 30 p.m
we received a 911 call in regards to a
shooting
in the 1600 block of davis place which
is behind me
upon officer arrival they located three
victims
suffering from gunshot wounds
upon that those victims were transported
to
umc where we just learned that one has
to come to their
injuries the victims are believed to be
in their
late 20s early 30s as for
the preliminary investigation it has
revealed that two armed assailants
approached a group behind me
and then for reasons unknown at this
time they began firing and at this time
detectives in csi
are on scene they are looking into all
investigative leads and conducting a
thorough investigation
now the person that did pass away a man
or woman
it is a man
we do not know the name we do not know
the age as for the coroner they will
release
the name of the victim upon their
investigation
and upon notifying next of kin are there
any suspects
north las vegas police a shooting
investigation we are told that one
person has died two others were hurt
men just came up to a group up in north
las vegas near
las vegas boulevard and owens and
started firing at that group again
three people shot two hurt and one has
died of course stay with eight news now
for the very latest as this develops and
of course you can follow on our website
eightnewsnow.com